[Music]
oh we didn't even we just kind of
skipped right past the whole part of
facebook where employees can get in the
building yeah that was crazy yeah
that part was nuts yeah so like i guess
what was broken was or the dns or
whatever was
i don't know how it was related to like
the internet of things
on the actual campus but yeah
basically people's id cards didn't work
there's people that showed up to fix the
issue and they couldn't get in the
building
good security i guess yeah
i guess but i mean yeah
or really bad security i watched a clip
of [ __ ] kramer
you know on like uh
i think that scott kramer yeah that's
the that's the [ __ ] you know
fast money guy right tim kramer jim
cramer yeah scott kramer he's like on
one of those [ __ ] cnbc shows he's
like i think
with this whistleblower thing and what's
going on today
it's gonna be damaged i'm like no it's
not
it's not yeah they make a [ __ ] ton of
money yeah
advertisers don't really care about
morals like
they're just gonna
yeah yeah this is just i mean at this
point
the only thing that can happen is the
government stepping in and regulating
social media i don't know it's like
we're changing teenagers brain chemistry
yeah at this point yeah what i'm saying
yeah that's why you can't watch porn if
you're i mean you can but like if you're
under 18
or drink or do anything like that yeah
and at this point if there's something
that is making
like kids want to kill themselves it's
like yeah
it makes adults want to kill themselves
so
yeah now it's now it's even worse i mean
bro
what the thing that stuck out to me
about the whistleblower situation was
like oh her her lawyer was like
facebook has an obligation to tell like
to convey material things to its
investors i'm like you think it's
investors are going to give a [ __ ] that
they chose yeah hey by the way we chose
to make more money so your dividends
were fatter um
some kids want to kill themselves but
hey they're not my kids yeah
i don't let my kids use the phone so
it's fine with me with me at regulation
i just
they want it like that cringe clip of
that senator being like will you
eliminate finsta
i didn't see that so i saw
a tweet or something but i didn't watch
the video center's like
will you remove finn stuff and it's this
rep from facebook it's like vince um i'm
not sure vinsta is a slang term like
it's one of your products she's like
it's it's not it's not it's a type of
account he's like i wish they understood
that's the only way that it's that any
change is going to happen is if they
actually have anyone in the government
that understands the way social media
works how could that i mean that guy
grew up when cars ran on steam yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying yeah like he
doesn't even [ __ ] get what a computer
is this finsta it's one of your products
will you remove finn's are you committed
to removing finsta
i wish someone pulled out a gun and just
shot him right there
i wish they were like uh
yeah sure yeah yeah well yeah we'll
remove fence stuff for sure yeah we'll
definitely move we'll remove it we'll
get rid of it there's a bad product
anyways so you're you're as as of today
finsta it's done yeah you have my word
for it yeah you go on our site right now
you search finsta you will not find a
product with that name okay we cool here
we all good yeah all right i'm taking
off thank you senator and then as they
leave the room he's like so when you say
you'll remove it senator they're not
here anymore yeah huh yeah what what
[Laughter]
stands up there's pee and [ __ ] coming
down his pants
it like
why are elected officials allowed to be
older than 45
elected officials need to be able to do
50 push-ups run three miles and like
solve basic algebra
if that was the requirement none of
these dudes would be in there it
legitimately makes me so angry
these are the people that like are have
responsibility over the free world burn
this man
and this was in
like this was in response to what
what
facebook
i know but it was it about
probably related stuff probably like the
papers or like the whistle-blowing
situation that's the thing is like even
if you blow the whistle the people who
are in charge of like doing something
about it are like so how do i log into
my facebook yeah i want to check this
thing out see what everyone's talking
about why is everyone so upset
are those breasts
what the hell is queuing on that seems
interesting yeah
oh look there's a group of people
celebrating at the capitol i don't even
know where he got finn stuff because
that's probably the part of instagram
like having offense does probably the
part that's good about social media
people not giving a [ __ ] what they post
and following only the people they like
look at this [ __ ]
[Music]
will you commit to ending finn stuff
[Laughter]
he thought he just did something senator
again let me explain we don't actually
we don't actually do
do finsta
what finsta refers to is young people
setting up accounts where they want they
want to have uh more privacy you refer
to it as privacy from their parents what
what in my interaction with teens what i
found is that they sometimes like to
have a an account where they can
interact just with their with a smaller
group of of friends
vince is one of your actually vince is
one of your products or services we're
not talking about google or apple
it's facebook correct
vince is slang for for a type of account
okay
it's not that type of account
we i i'm not sure under understanding
now
they're asking
now what is an account
[Laughter]
they have [ __ ] dracula up there
asking questions about
so funny because it's like to him she's
kind of like she must seem like she's
backpedaling but she's just like there's
no possible way i can answer this
question right now yeah
yeah how do i even describe this to
someone who literally does not
understand anything about this it's like
all right man will you end this type of
account
yes
[Laughter]
yeah we'll do that
as i said it's done yeah no more fences
today out of all the questions that this
dude is asking he's asking the most
like unimportant one
what about the [ __ ] capacity to just
turn up social angst
finn stuff
like they're trying to angle it on like
this teenager aspect it's like bro
they're hiding pictures from their
parents on their fin studs
i think that's the biggest issue here
it's like no turn off kylie jenner's
account yeah
that would work that would be a start
turn it off turn off all the kardashians
accounts yeah boom
bro that's a 10
increase in women happiness right there
bro
it's [ __ ] is doing all this because he
just wants to get into his
granddaughter's fence though yeah yeah
exactly i don't like it this is fighting
drug use
from her parents on her finsta it's like
no she's just posting funny selfies on
there probably this guy literally drinks
blood and lives in a coffin like
we i'm not sure i under understand
exactly what you're asking what i can
say is that based on what we've seen in
terms of of teens using those kinds of
accounts we've actually given them
additional privacy options to to address
to address those kinds of issues where
they want more privacy so that they can
have more privacy
well
i don't think that's an answer to my
question
because you're not you're not asking
there is no answer to your question dude
there's no answer it's not even a real
question it's so annoying man
yeah so i'm talking about google or
apple here
well yeah what what
now imagine this guy marching in with a
[ __ ] bill to regulate the internet
like they're going to write some crazy
[ __ ] where it's like you can't be asian
on the internet you're like well
[Laughter]
but i want to watch squid games all
right
it's just like god man it's like of all
the things like when you know when like
ajit pai and the whole you know net
neutrality thing like hearing all these
bozos get involved it's like oh just
[ __ ] die go away and exactly and
meanwhile mark zuckerberg is like
yeah
yeah keeping stupid yeah selling ads to
everyone and anyone that dude man
sorry guys sorry to get so political
sorry to call yeah sorry to make it
political by calling a senator dracula
facebook is poison though it really is
[ __ ] poison but people are catching
on i feel like a lot of twitter was like
all right like mark zuckerberg tweeted
and was like hey guys we know people
rely on your services or our services
sorry to like you know speak to the ones
you love
and everyone's like now keep it off no
one gives a [ __ ] yeah
please this is awesome
this is the best day i've had in two
years
i feel like everyone got a little
excited though they're like oh my god
facebook is down it's never coming back
it's like shut the [ __ ] up dude this is
like one of the biggest tech companies
on earth yeah yeah yeah it's not just
gonna poof yeah you know even if someone
had a bad day
at their servers up in like stockholm or
whatever and poured coffee on one
trust me yeah
they will make sure that [ __ ] comes back
online uh there was a funny tweet too
that said that because facebook's stock
dipped five percent that
uh mark zuckerberg lost like eight
billion dollars in yeah in net worth and
it was yes seven seven billion dollars
and so he he basically fell behind
bill gates and
other guys oh god become
not one of the top five richest people
on earth or something [ __ ]
we'll check back in seven so suck it
mark ooh
oh how does it feel to be the fourth
yeah sounds bad why don't you cry about
it
all right he's probably really angry
about that he's that he's gonna he
probably is when that should happen
turning that knob up yeah he drove to
work yeah yeah he didn't drive to work
usually it's like mark's in the building
and he's just walking in there with this
alien ass tongue just like
no he's riding on one of those big wheel
things yeah like the single wheel
[ __ ] plank
clear the doors clear the doors marcus
and he's cruising around the corners
i picture it more creepy like it's just
like he just kind of leans but frozen
like a
like a video game character or something
okay like he doesn't really have hips
about it right right like it's just like
a slight tilt
he goes straight to the server room hops
off it
like lizard tongue licking his face and
[ __ ] eating flies and just
yeah
that was one of the crazy lines in the
60 minutes interview they were like
there's like some
political party that basically initiated
like a genocide in myanmar over facebook
huh yeah
jesus christ
but yeah facebook's important for you
know being able to communicate with the
ones you love yeah yeah exactly right
mark yeah
good last like notch on that knob
genesis genocide yeah
that's the one you gotta put your key in
and turn it and then you go to the last
yeah
this will teach them to whenever text
talk [ __ ] about facebook
ever again
facebook go live yeah yeah
yeah it's the genocide button
facebook
go live
then he calls jack cuss you mark
and then they're just at their they are
competing to create the most social div
like divisiveness yeah
jack is like [ __ ] angry yeah
facebook did it did a genocide
what can we do
sorry i just think they're all evil
no they are they really are anyways it's
crazy that
in
what 10 years
they've just it was like at the very
start it was like this is innovation
this is the new way so exciting this is
this is society now so exciting it's
because
it's because we are all just constantly
being fed dopamine by these apps yeah
[ __ ] this rules because we were just
getting high yep and now we finally
realized it's like all these are
this is bad yeah
you